i dropped a bomb
the whole world is watching for my next
move you're the number one trending
topic ahead of tater tots and the pope
followed you wow okay no this is not the
is this the real
no i don't think this is hope
my family have disappeared i need to
know where everyone is and what
everyone's thinking
there he is the little man who started
this big war
right now i'm the real you sure and i'm
the real you
you sound deranged
as i understand it you want to take down
your dad without implicating yourself
correct and without damaging the company
to the extent that you lose control at
your shareholder meeting you have an
actual case ken yes i can kill him
is he gonna watch could we make a note
in the minutes that he's watching us
there's blood in the water sharks are
coming brooklyn's a company i really was
a company today investigation's
looking pretty bad i'm focused on not
going to jail logan says we have to take
these
cyanide pills
it's a mint you doofus
no one's on my side in this i need you
to protect me pinky
if we don't beef up soon i think we end
up someone's lunch
when will your father die uh with due
respect no no no obviously hugely
looking forward to my father dying right
where's this
this friction
i thought my family was up this
is next level
roman is a knucklehead shiv is a fake
and kenny is screwy i've seen more than
any of them
this life is not for
everyone it's a number on a piece of
paper
it's a fight for a knife in the mud
i'm a good guy
i'm better than you
well beast em
we'll go full beast
[Music]
you